are you aware of psychedelics being used
as a channel of communication
i'll tell you that i know that there's a
lot of people out there trying to
utilize that right now and they have
their own beliefs
and they have some certain commonality
of experience when we're talking about
those that are approaching approaching
it from a scientific fashion those that
are
um connected with
um pardon me for not remembering his
name the terence mckenna's brother
um
is doing a great deal yeah dennis is
doing a lot of great work down south i
believe in central america
and setting up an institute and a
college
to study
these things their effects in a
pragmatic scientific and in fashion
utilizing control groups and modern
therapy i think that's very important
because it it is the the undiscovered
country of human consciousness is to go
down the rabbit rabbit hole of
of uh loss of self frankly
um
now does that tie directly into what we
see in the skies and what we purport to
and what we hoped might be have crashed
pardon me for hoping a crash on anyone
but hoping that there might be evidence
right you know we all hope that there's
that eventually some day we might find
that that smoking gun we all talk about
that gives us clarity
but
i still don't know if the spectrum we're
looking at i feel like our needle goes
all over the place all the time because
we're using a word like phenomenon and i
think that's important i think i think
the the facile idea that we have taken
the word ufo and replaced it with some
new no we used a better
word
because most of stuff that i am
encountering regardless of whether it's
unidentified or an object it's certainly
not exhibiting flight characteristics
and that just gets under my skin
that we're constantly saying flight
flying flying listen that's a that's a
kindergarten attitude to think it's in
the sky it's flying
it's i'm sorry to say it like that if
that's not
that we need folks
to
get out of that muck get get get up get
up a level
on some of this stuff it really opens up
new doors of thought it opens up new
possibilities as to what we're working
with when you start looking at it
differently and not in the science
fiction and as you've been told aspect
i agree we need to be more accurate with
our terminology right this goes back to
what sean was saying the beginning as
far as our lexicon you know but please
do you know be accurate when you when
you speak
because it you know what words have
meaning and and a lot of people just
kind of throw words around and
you know they're not really doing their
due diligence understanding and it
confuses things and
you know we have to be accurate that's
why science is is
to where it is today because it involves
accuracy
math right um
you want to be accurate when you're when
you're describing things like this
especially something that we don't know
be accurate in the unknowns um and i
think that's you know sean said it
perfectly you know you have
flight is a fundamental you have four
fundamental forces you have thrust lift
drag and weight
and when you understand those you have
flight you have control surfaces you
have wings and rudders and ailerons and
elevators
but we're not seeing any of those
associated technologies and people say
well it's a semantics no it's it it is
but it's important it's important
semantics right otherwise just call
every animal an animal right forget if
it's a blue whale or a human being or an
elephant it's just an animal well no
there's differences key differences and
we have to be we have to be mindful of
that